welcome to real world examples on
optimizing.net performance
I'm Stefan Newcastle I'm Icelandic
a principal software engineer at
lucinity in regular
also Microsoft MVP and have a pinpoint
contributor maintainer
and that's a link to my blog if you want
to check it out
I'm gonna go over a few topics
here today
a lot of them have to do with memory
allocations
on the garbage collector in in.net
value versus reference types that's like
Heap stack memory
techniques for example for memory
pooling stack allocations
boxing serialization ndns
channels which I wish more people knew
about and then some benchmarking and
profiling tools let's see if we can get
all over all of this
so starting at the beginning with memory
allocations dotnet is a managed runtime
as you know
what that means is that when you start
up a.net process it allocates
contigues a heap of memory for each
process and it manages it for you
actually takes care of allocating and
cleaning up the memory that you use
and this process is maintained by the
garbage collector in.net
now there's a link there to the
fundamentals of coverage collection
and to optimize the performance the
garbage collector splits the Heap into
three generations called zero one and
two
and that's to help it manage
like different lifetimes of objects that
you're allocating
it also has a separate Heap for large
objects there's objects that are bigger
than 85 000 bytes which is called the
large object Heap get to that in a bit
so the garbage collector basically
consists of three phases
and this is what it runs for every
generation that it collects it marks the
objects that are still alive
in that generation
reload kitchen if it has to and then it
compacts that Heap for that generation
and this is done to make space for other
objects that you might be allocating
now the generations are like I said zero
one and two generation zeros where all
your new objects get allocated when you
create them
reference types that is
and if generation zero is full the
garbage collector has to run a
collection on that generation releasing
objects so it can make space for the new
objects that you're allocating
an object that survived get promoted up
to gen one that's sort of how it keeps
track of uh like short short-lived
objects and log lived objects
concept compact that generation
gen 1 very similar
if there is not enough memory that gets
freed up in generation zero it does the
same thing that it didn't generation
zero to gen 1.
survivors get promoted to Gen 2 which is
the final one and that's pretty much
where all long-lived objects end up in
the end
and similar to generation zero if there
still is enough space it's going to run
a Gen 2 collection
Gen 2 collection is a bit different so
objects there are usually just objects
that live for long
that is they've survived through two
collections this generation zero and one
and collecting a generation as you see
means that it has been doing all
generations before it as well so what
generation 2 collection is called a full
garbage collection
and by definition is the most expensive
one that's also the old the only uh
collection that actually
collects things from the large object
Heap but the large trucks were cheap due
to like those mostly being like big
objects is not compacted
so generation 2 is expensive
to run quickly over like reference
versus value types preference types are
the types that you normally
knew up or our object okay examples of
those are strings objects classes and
arrays
the value types do not get allocated in
Heap memory so they don't get cleaned up
because they don't have to
those are in bytes characters for
examples bulls and struct structs like
install classes
now the difference between those for
example when your colleague methods is
reference types get copied by reference
so you can think like when you're
sending a reference type as a parameter
to a method
the value of it is not copied you're
just sending a pointer to that reference
type value types however get copied so
like if you create a string send it to a
method that method changes the string
it's going to change the original object
however ever if you send an integer into
a method
and you for example incremented the
original integer is not going to get
modified because it was copied before it
was sent to the sent to the method
so
knowing all this then we can pretty much
at least get a good sense of how we can
increase performance like best thing of
course is to not allocate at all because
then the garbage collection doesn't have
to do anything but that's unrealistic
we're always going to have to allocate
something
so a good aim for us to do is to try to
keep the objects that we have
short-lived
and to keep them small to avoid them
ending up on a large object keep because
as I said that only gets cleaned up as
part of a Gen 2 collection
to sort of
show you a little bit of an example of
this
if we want to convert a string to utf-8
bytes
this is something that a lot of us have
probably done at some point in time
however
this is where an allocation takes place
because we need to put that string
create a byte array for it and
converted into that byte array
but we can actually avoid this
allocation so some tricks that's where
we get to memory pooling
there's a class called the array pool
it's good because it actually
keeps a bucket of arrays for different
types that's why it's a generic
and you can rent the Rays from it and
then work with it and once you're done
working with it you can return it again
now there's a gotcha here you have to
remember to return it because if you
finish up all the arrays in the pool
then you have to turn them it's gonna
have to start creating new ones but it's
not going to clean the other ones up
because they're being referenced by the
pool so if you don't return them you're
going to end up with a memory leak
and a good way to do that is to use a
try and finally I'm actually not doing
that in this example just to keep it
short but this is how it works for
example you
rent you rent bytes from the array pool
and you can actually use that array for
example to turn a string into UTF
encoded bytes
and then that get byte call is not going
to allocate any memory because it's
already been allocated as part of the
pool so you can reuse it again and again
there is a helper you can use which is
called the memory pool it's very similar
to the array pool actually uses an
arrival underneath but it helps you take
care of the investing and returning by
implementing an eye disposable
so you can just use by using declaration
for the memory that you wrapped and
it'll get returned eventually when
you're done using it
another one of those things that you can
do is stack allocations
they're a bit different because they are
not allocating objects on the Heap so
they're not creating objects that need
to be cleaned up
so by definition they are often a lot
more performant a lot faster to do but
there are caveats to it there are
limitations
you don't have an endless amount of
Stack space I think we've all seen what
happens for example if you have a
an infinite recursion you end up with a
stack Overflow exception because you're
not out of Stack memory
that's why you cannot like do this or
use endless amount of it there are other
limitations as well you cannot use it in
async methods
because the compiler will generate all
sorts of State machines and Method jumps
between it so there's no way for it to
keep track of the stack allocated memory
and you have a limited memory space you
should never assume that you have more
than just a few kilobytes of memory to
use
also when you're stack allocating memory
it is best to
allocate a constant size because that
allows the compiler to do a lot of
optimizations to make the allocations
faster
there is one
hint in there which I didn't put on the
slide you should never use a stacker
location in the loop for obvious reasons
because you will of course eventually
end up with a stack Overflow exception
if you do that
now
there is a trick you can use to combine
stack allocations and the array pool
where you can pretty much at runtime
decide which one you're going to do
so in this case we decided okay we're
gonna allocate or have a limit of like
one kilobyte
we create
a knowable reference told by the rail
which is the pulled array which will
only get populated if we need to go to
the ray pool and can't use the stack
allocation
then we figure out how many parts we're
going to need if it's under the stack
allocation limit we use the stack
allocation otherwise we use the array
pool
and then at the end we check if we
actually erected an array and return it
if we have to
now
to put this into perspective and sort of
show you what happens like with the
utf-8 example if we run a benchmark on
this uh
for like three different sizes a string
that has 64 bytes
or 64 characters 512 characters and 1024
characters
for short strings you will actually see
that
just like directly allocating it just
using the the plane method is actually
faster than using a memory pool
and the reason for that is because the
memory pool
like I said uses eye disposable so
there's overhead involved there it has
to have a try finally around the eye
disposable it has to call the dispose
method so for short strings memory pool
is actually more expensive there
but as the strings get larger you can
see that the standard method gets slower
in every case and in all of these cases
stack allocations are the fastest ones
if you look at the column there that
says allocated you can see how much
memory is being allocated in each case
but you can see for example when I have
a string of length 64 I'm allocating 88
bytes of memory
there are there are extra 24 bytes there
that are being allocated every time and
I'll get to it later why that is
you also see that those same 24 bytes
are allocated in the memory pool
instance
[Music]
and that brings us to boxing
when you have a value type that you need
to convert or
not convert you need to store it as
maybe it implements an interface
the runtime can't store it directly it
has to put it inside an object class and
store it somewhere so even if you have a
value type if you treat it as an
interface
you're going to be allocating memory
because it needs to be put into that
object
so for example this happens when you
wrap a value in an object class for
example let's say you have let's say you
have a list of like icomparables if you
put an integer into the list you're
going to allocate memory because
it's going to need to treat that value
type as an interface and interfaces are
actually objects
so
memory needs to be allocated on the Heap
every time you need to box a value type
the memory allocated on 32-bit machines
is always well at least 16 bytes depends
on the size of the value type being
boxed and it's at least 24 bytes on 65
4-bit machine that's the 24 price that I
was showing you earlier
because we had
we had our memory pool used as an eye
disposable so it needed to wrap it in an
interface that's why that method
actually allocated 24 bytes even though
we were using full memory
and this is the reason for example if we
put an integer
and box it
this is the object that actually gets
created in the memory layout you get an
object header that depends on if you
have a 32-bit or 64-bit machine how big
it is
it needs a method table pointer than it
needs the actual value
and because it needs to like align
everything it needs to align the objects
to like specific architectures it needs
to have eight bytes for padding as well
so in the example here boxing let's say
I create an interface
I want to create a serialization
interface
and to minimize allocations I create a
struct to implement that interface so
all that interface does is it takes a
spanner bytes and it's supposed to write
that object into that span
another method calls you realize which
takes any object that or any object or
structure whatever it is that implements
the interface and serialize it to the
bytes in there
but again to minimize allocations I
created a struct I'm using stack
allocated bytesville destination so
although there are no allocations there
and I call the share release method
but because we're treating it as an
interface this is going to allocate
memory regardless this is always going
to allocate on at least on my machine
which is 64 bits at least 24 bytes of
memory
but there is actually a sneaky way that
we can get around this
we can use generics to trick the
compiler
to say
my serialized method is going to be
generic this time but I'm going to
restrict it to taking objects that
implement this interface so when I
actually now call this method
the compiler is going to basically
create an implementation of this method
using the struct directly instead of the
interface so no boxing will take place
but there's
two other things that actually happen as
well
in the previous version we were actually
using the interface it also needs to do
what's called the virtual method call
because it's receiving an interface it
doesn't know what the object is that's
coming in so it can't do any
optimizations well it technically can if
you have very few types implementing the
interface but usually you should
consider that it doesn't
and that brings us to something called
inlining
if we have a small method
that
doesn't do a lot then they compiler will
sometimes instead of making your code
call that method simply take the content
of the method and put it instead of a
method call
so it saves a method call
and the like the code version the like
generated code version of the method
becomes a little bit bigger but it's
faster because there's no overhead in
having to like copy parameters and
everything else
so this actually gives us three benefits
we get rid of the boxing
we get really virtual call on the
interface and we actually allow the
compiler to start inlining things
and to
for example in this case I like the
implementation of MySQL like the Bison
was just taking like an integer
converted to bytes because integers just
four bytes in memory
the difference in performance here is
actually quite dramatic
if we use the interface call
like pretty much every call takes six
nanoseconds
but using the generic interface it goes
down to 0.4 it's actually 93 faster than
the other one
now just to be clear this is a micro
optimization like you might have a lot
of code that you would change to do this
and you wouldn't notice anything in your
application but if your application is
doing a lot of
doing a lot of things with either
interfaces or struct types you should
see a difference
and speaking of serialization that
brings us to indian-ness
is
something that is dependent on the
architecture of the machine that you're
running machines can be like big Indian
or little Indian and then when it comes
to networking
a lot of a lot of libraries or protocols
say that like you should be sending
things in network byte order Network
byte order is just big Indian
to
show you what I mean by engineers
if I take an inside integer with this
value Which con like converts to the hex
like AABB ccdd
on a big ending machine this is stored
in that order in memory it's going to be
stored as a a b b c c d d but on a
little Indian machine which is probably
most of your machines it's actually
stored in memory as ddccpaa
so if you would send this
send its integer over a network that's
expecting this to be in the correct
order you would actually be reversing
the integer without knowing it so
this is something you need to be aware
of for example if you're writing
cross-platform serialization code we're
sending stuff over the network according
to like different protocols
so there are of course ways that we can
just get around this we can like detect
the ndns we'll just reverse the bytes if
we want to and this is what about
rabbitmq.net client used to do
this is this is not very pretty code
like if you if you've used
bit wise like operations like ending or
or shifting things
you might realize what it's doing it's
basically taking the bytes in that long
and it's reversing them but it's trying
to do it all like without allocating
anything
so there are no temporary variables that
are really being used that require
allocation
but of course for us to be able to like
to do this we need to read it as an
unsigned integer so we're like sure that
all the bytes are in the correct place
however there is an easier way to do
this
because.net has a thing called binary
Primitives
which does the same thing
we can read eight bytes we can simply
say like read this as a big Indian
there are also right in 64 big Indian
and right operations for most other
value types that you have
and to visualize this if you look at the
actual assembly code that gets generated
for these two methods
it looks like this
and I'm going to highlight the important
part
the old method is on the left those are
all of the CPU instructions that needed
to be run
just to make sure that we were returning
the bytes followed along in the correct
order
using a binary Primitives class
it boils down to one instruction because
it turns out our CPUs actually have a
single instruction that just does this
take this memory thing reverse it store
it somewhere else
and again like with the other Benchmark
that we saw
the difference is actually quite
dramatic
this the new method is actually 95
faster and I think we can all agree on
which one is more readable as well
so that brings me to something called
channels
this is one of the things that I wish
more people knew about
um if you've ever
if you've ever written for example a
concurrent application that uses
multiple threads and you need to pass
things back and forth
you might have you might have used
a lot of like different constructs like
cues you might have used like locks
around them to make sure that like one
thing is pulling stuff from the cube one
thing is putting stuff in there this is
what channel
s do for you
it's made to
sort of do this producer consumer
pattern
it has optimizations for different
scenarios like do I have multiple Riders
do I have a single Rider single reader
multiple readers whatever
and it has both async and synchronous
interfaces as well because as soon as
you start doing something like this
async
you have to do a lot of complex things
for example you might have used a q and
a lock you might have used a concurrent
cue in semaphores and then you start
running into like task completion
sources if you want to have this async
and whatnot
channels just make this easy because
they take care of all this for you
out of the box Channel comes with two
implementations there's an unbounded one
which is basically says I can put as
many items in the channel as I want
which is good like if you want to do
things quickly but you have to be really
sure that you can actually process
things faster than they come in because
otherwise you're going to run out of
memory eventually
but for those cases you actually have
the bounded Channel
the boundary channel can set a maximum
number of items that can stay in the
channel
so it's great for buffering things up
you can say like I want to create a
channel that takes like 100 items and if
it's full the producer is going to have
to wait
until the reader is actually taking
stuff out of it before it can put new
stuff in
if we look at just a simplified example
of this
let's say we have the Creator method at
the top that processes an integer and
just to simulative work we're going to
randomly sleep for up to 100
milliseconds
asynchronously of course
then we write to the console if this is
number this number is odd or even
then we create another method an
asynchronous method which processes
Channel and you can see that it takes
Channel reader as a parameter
it can asynchronously for reach through
it so for every item that comes in
asynchronously
it's gonna call the process method
if there are no items
to read this method is not going to
block and take up one of our threads
it's just going to yield it back and it
could go do something else
then we create a bounded Channel 10
items
and we start the consumer process now at
that point it's not going to do anything
because there's nothing in the channel
then we just do a simple for Loop put
the Thousand items in the channel
asynchronously of course because we have
to wait for the reader to take them up
because we can just keep maximum of 10
items in there at a time
and we write when we've actually written
something to it and once we're done
writing we complete the channel
and we have to complete the channel to
let the reader know that there are no
more items going to be coming through
otherwise the reader would just run
forever but this is to signal to it and
say hey like you're done
and then we wait for the consumer to
finish
and
if we just run this really quickly
can
this is what it does
just runs
very easily it's just two-way
synchronous tasks one is writing always
reading television telling you if it's
an odd or even number
but
we of course have multi-core machines so
we might want to do this in parallel
take advantage of them
when we're using channels we can
actually just focus on that part of the
code we don't have to worry about uh
like do I have multiple readers or
multiple writers
channels just take care of that for us
so all we got to do really is change the
processing method or the one that
actually reads on the channel
and this is what I actually like in this
example because doing this in parallel
is actually simpler than to not doing it
because we have asynchronous parallel
helpers for this
and to give you an idea of the
difference
we can do something like this I think
this is even still running
doing it in parallel becomes
something like this
and it's done
taking full advantage of the course that
we have on our machine without really
having to focus anything on how we were
producing consuming things just focusing
on the actual thing reading from the
channel
so
gone over a few things that we can
actually use in these cases
now this talk is about how these things
were actually applied in the real world
and I actually applied these things on
the rabbitmq.net client
rabbitmq for those who don't know is
like a it's a
well it's a queue message queue and it
uses the amqp protocol
just to give you a very quick overview
what it does
connections have channels like these are
not the same channels I was just showing
you this is the webmq term Channel
for multiplexing purposes so you can be
using the connection for for multiple
things at a time and channels issue
commands like create a queue declare a
queue delete it or publish a message
whatever
commands eventually when they get sent
to the server are serialized into frames
frames are just like
just by the race really
they consist of a header payload and
marker
to show you sort of like a very simple
explanation of the layout a frame looks
like this one byte for the type two
butts for the channel
payload length is 4 byte
payload different depending on what is
actually being sent if I'm creating a
queue I need to send the queue name and
other things if I'm publishing a message
I might be sending headers
Etc and then there's an end marker
telling you
that like this is the end of the frame
the payload layout is
like what you would actually be put into
the frame payload
two bytes for the class ID class ID can
be like Q or exchange whatever and then
the method ID which is like create
delete publish
things like that and then the arguments
that go with it like the queue name for
example
so we can see that we have
things we need to serialize things we
need to deserialize and work with
so what the webmq client did before we
actually made these changes
when it was sending a command
this is what it did step one was it
created a memory stream
it wrapped that memory stream in a
network binary writer which was
basically a helpful helper class that
did all the serialization like big
Indian serialization other things
wrote the commands to the network binary
writer which put it on the memory stream
grab the resulting byte array out of the
memory stream because now we have
serialized this into bytes
set that to the actual Network stream
needed to lock it of course because we
can't be having many people send trying
to write bytes to the network at a time
wrote it and had to release the lock
now there are multiple problems here
related to what we were just going over
always creating a memory stream is
expensive because it's allocating a new
byte array under the membership at all
times now you you can't tell the memory
stream to use an existing byte array if
you have one
and you can tell it to like you can
initialize it to a certain size also if
you want but in the cases where we're
having commands we have no idea how big
or small they're going to be
memory stream depending on how big the
comment is might have to resize the
array and that means allocate a new
array copy everything over making more
space
and they might have to do this multiple
times if the command was really big for
example if you're publishing a large
message
another problem was that the helper
class the network binary writer always
assumed it was running on a little
Indian architecture so usually a pretty
safe assumption to make
but if it was to be run on other
architectures
this would fail
there's a lot of custom serialization
logic which I'll show you for example
with the big method that was doing all
the like bit shifting ending boring
whatnot
doing a lot of these things is not good
for the CPU because like you're you're
basically like creating a very big
assembly code out of it doesn't inline
very well because it gets complex
which is not good for the compiler
either
and doing all the Locking of course on
the connections slows things down as
well like if we were doing a lot of
things in parallel
you would be getting into a lot of lock
contentions you're like nope you have to
wait till I get the lock so I can like
write this Frame because of someone else
is writing another frame or a big frame
so every frame means like had to take a
lock write it release it so it added up
quickly in case you had like high
concurrency
every frame implementation then had like
knew how to serialize it was a class
and like I showed you earlier classes
are reference types so that means even
if we were just creating a simple
command that was creating a queue we
needed to start allocating bytes
or extra bytes at least
so we need to figure out where the solar
problem so we thought okay instead of
writing conventional memory stream let's
just Implement a frame interface
knows how to calculate its size so we
can actually know beforehand how many
bytes we're going to need
and then the interface like tells it or
instructs is on that it needs to know
how to write itself to those bytes
we changed the serialization Desolation
to use the binary Primitives as I showed
you before so like most properly
cross-platform code was a lot easier to
read as well
then we decided to use the channels as a
buffer between the connection
and the outgoing frames
so instead of always taking a lock on an
upper connection
and start writing we will just put it on
a channel
so after the changes
what we do like how we would actually
send commands to the webmq server is we
would calculate the command size
because we have an interface to do that
we ranked an array that is big enough
for us to write into it
we again have an interface we know how
to write to that array
send the array to the channel writer
and there's just a single reader picking
everything up from the channel
writing it to a network stream and once
it's done it sends the array back to the
array pool
so in this case we're not well we're
hoping we at least not allocate anything
to validate that these changes were
actually doing what they were supposed
to be doing
we needed to profile and Benchmark to
changes so created a simple wrapping
Cube test application what it did was it
opened the connection to the server
Creator Channel and subscriber sends 50
000 messages gets it back
with uh we decided to have like a big
payload
wait until it receives them all back and
then quits
so doing the math on this like we were
sending less than two gigabytes of data
over the network should be
no
before we actually made all these
changes
this is what the revenue client did
it allocated 7.14 gigabytes of memory to
send 50 000 messages
so to send less than two gigabytes of
messages we were allocating
more than seven gigabytes those are not
like allocations that were all being
done at the same time so like the the
client didn't take 70 gigabytes of
memory like it was constantly like
allocating it and cleaning it up
but you can see that like it's
allocating a bunch of bytes it's
allocating a bunch of memory streams
and it's actually allocating or creating
and the garbage collection having to
collect like four million objects
so this is not very optimal
after we did the changes that we
that I just showed you
it went down to this
99 megabytes in total allocated to send
this because we can simply reuse all our
flight arrays again and again and again
also reduce the number of objects
allocated from like over 4 million down
to 1.8 and this was actually just by
making
these changes that I actually did in
there there was room for a lot of
improvement more
and it has actually been improved I
think we're actually down to like using
this using this same Benchmark I think
currently we're around 30 or 40
megabytes that get allocated
so this is sort of a way that you can
actually
apply things like this in the real world
with actual real world benefits
but
doing this is as with everything else
you can't just like go
all out and start optimizing everything
without actually knowing what you're
supposed to be optimizing and so we're
going to need some tools to do that
to go over some of them
there are if you're using visual studio
it has actually a built-in profiling
tool which is really really nice and has
actually been improved a lot lately
it's become a lot faster than it used to
be
and it's built into like I said built
into Visual Studio
but if you're not reusing visual studio
uh jetbrains has memory allocation tools
as well that you can do memory profiling
on
you can see for example it does uh it
shows you like visually how much memory
is in each generation like the
generation zero generation one two
or the large objective for that matter
and it shows you like the difference in
what happens when it actually does
collections
it also has a really really nice
snapshotting feature so you can take
snapshots at your applications running
and actually compare them so you can see
like the difference in for example how
many strings I've been allocating
between the snapshots or how many of
them are getting cleaned up or how many
of them are still left
so you can see use that for example to
track memory leaks
another tool jetbrains has is dot Trace
now this is a CPU profiler so instead of
profiling your memory usage you can use
this to
like profile your application and see
where it's actually spending all the GPU
time you can also use it to see if you
have a multi-thread application you can
see all the context switches going on
see which tasks are running or which
threads are actually doing anything it
can also help you spot for example if
you have threads that are blocking or
waiting for something when they should
when they should be like yielding or
attached to other threads so it's very
good to to look at threat utilization as
well
I forgot to mention for example Visual
Studio tools they actually have both a
CPU and a memory profiler built in uh so
that's pretty handy
if you wanna really get down to
something Nitty Gritty uh you can use
perfume
it's not
it does not have the Jose it's not have
the best user interface but if you get
used to it like I would not recommend
you start using this tool like to begin
with use something simple to begin with
but this tool is really really powerful
it can show you a lot of things if you
know what you're looking for and you can
do CPU allocations no CPU sorry
profiling memory allocations they can
even start looking at things like when
you're jumping from manage code into
native code you can tell you for example
like
if you have a managed application that's
opening and like opening a lot of files
it can actually show you once it goes
output to the operating system to open a
file and it can show it like ah Defender
is pulling in there trying to like scan
the file before I'm opening it and
everything else so it's really really
good
but take some time getting used to
benchmarks the benchmarks I show you or
like the results I showed you were
created with benchmark.net
benchmark.net is really released use and
it's really powerful it's great for
these micro benchmarks it's not very
good at showing you for example like
it's not very good at benchmarking an
entire application that does a lot of
things it's best for benchmarking like
small pieces of code
and it gives you results in like
multiple formats you can get a text
format markdown format it can give you
reports for example of as we saw the
memory allocations it can even give you
reports of the assembly code that gets
generated so you can start running this
seeing the difference in in code
generation
and a lot of other very very cool things
you can also you can also for example I
guess down here you can say I have a
benchmark I want you to run it on these
different types of the internet
framework and compare the results
so you can see the performance
improvements for example between.net
framework versions all.net corporations
for that matter
another tool that I'm
really fond of is
shortlab.io this is pretty much a
website
you just go there you paste in some
c-sharp code
they will actually compile it and it can
show you the results it can show you for
example if you
if you have a c-sharp code where you're
using a lot of like a lot of the new
syntax it can show you the actual
c-sharp code that it gets turned into
you can also show you the Intermediate
Language code IO code or even the
assembly code that gets generated
so this is really nice as well
it's easy for example if you want to
share like
share code generation with someone else
you can just like copy paste URLs and it
will actually the code is actually
usually a part of the part of the URL in
there
also has like in this case you can see
that probably in the middle there
there's an x64 you can like see how the
different code is generated depending on
what architecture you're picking so
that's that's a really nice thing
and another thing that
I'm really fond of is power up it's a
tool made by
Bartos adamsky I think I think I'm
pronouncing that correctly
but there's a tool he actually created
because he he likes looking at compilers
seeing like the different things
compilers do or different compilers a
lot different things they should be
doing and aren't doing
and this works not just for dotnet code
it's actually this can actually show you
code generation for I think golang rust
as well
so I'd highly recommend that you take a
look at this tool if you wanna if you
want to see what actually happens
so I think that's pretty much it I
decided to leave some room from for
questions if you have any
um
this is
a lot to go over
to digest so please bring them on if you
have any
can't see anything
any questions you have
right
yep
to you sorry it's a question if you can
use Channels with the RX Library yeah
all right
I not that I know of
but I would I would
I would guess that it would not be very
hard to do it might actually be a good
fit in some cases
it might be helpful
anyone else
you're gonna have to speak up because I
like I can't see if you're raising your
hands
[Applause]
all right
so thank you very much
my blog